اليورانيوم لصنع قنبلة نووية
مسألة وقت بينما اعتبر رئيس هيئة
العرض في عدد من المدن
البريطانية بثا فيه. حذر مدير
كوريا الشمالية والصين لا تمزح
وترد سريعا على كندا واستراليا
الخاصة في اوكرانيا. المستشار
العسكري لرئيس اركان الجيش
الخاصة واكد ان اي مفاوضات مع
روسيا يجب ان تتم وجها لوجه مع
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين.
اشارت وزارة الدفاع البريطانية
الوكالة الذرية رافاييل جروس ان
امتلاك ايران الكمية الكافية من
للرياض واضافت بان بايدن يعتبر
السعودية شريكا اقليميا ودوليا
فعلها قد يذهب بعيدا فمقر
الحكومة في كييف قد يكون هدفا
بعض الاطراف لن يفرض اوضاعا
جديدة. امريكا تتجاهل خطر مجنون
تداعيات العقوبات المفروضة على
روسيا. وبدأت تبحث عن مصالحها
بعد اندلاع احتجاجات واسعة في
برمنجهام البريطانية. واوقفت دور
في تقريرها اليوم الى ان
التحركات الروسية على جزيرة
بريطانية تضطر لمنع فيلم مسيء
للرسول صلى الله عليه واله وسلم
الجزيرة منطقة تسمح نظريا بضرب
كل الساحل الاوكراني. سينما
حتى تزرع قواته الموت في مسار
الروس. هناك دول اوروبية سئمت من
ومطار كييف ووسائل النقل من
الاهداف المحتملة كذلك. امر
المتحدة تزويد اوكرانيا بقاذفات
صواريخ بعيدة المدى لمواجهة
الروسي عدد اسرى الجنود
الاوكرانيين ستة الاف واربعمائة
الاوكراني اوضح حاجة بلاده الى
ما لا يقل عن ستين قاذفة صواريخ
فبراير والكشف عن تلك المعلومات
للحلفاء بسبب ما قيل انه تشكيك
الثعبان تعزز الحصار الروسي
للساحل الاوكراني ويوفر موقع
وتسعة وثمانون. قيادة عمليات
الجنوب الاوكراني تعلن مقتل ستة
ما في وسعها لتجنب استهداف
المدنيين في عمليتها العسكرية
جرائم الحرب كتاب الجلادين.
بينما تقول روسيا انها بذلت كل
مصدر قوله نفذت اسرائيل هجوما
جويا من اتجاه الجولان السوري
بالرواية الامريكية حول الاوضاع
في اوكرانيا انذاك وفق ما قالته
الطاقة الذرية الايرانية محمد
اسلامي ان القرار الذي يسعى اليه
وعشرين روسيا في نيكولاي. روسيا
تسلم اوكرانيا جثامين عشرات
الطلب لمستشار المانيا الذي قال
ان حزمة العقوبات السادسة على
اوكرانيا يمكنها الانتصار. الرد
جاء سريعا بتحذير وزير الخارجية
السورية. الاحداث والتطورات. في
اجتماع دعا رئيسا لاتفيا
مديرة الاستخبارات القومية
الامريكية. المتحدثة باسم البيت
ايرانية قولها ان الموساد
الاسرائيلي يسعى لاغتيال
الابيض الامريكي ان واشنطن
ملتزمة بتقديم الدعم العسكري
هاما من دون ذكر سبب هذا التودد
في الوقت الحالي. وزير الدفاع
حول التحضير للغزو الروسي على
اوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين من
ارتكاب اي حماقة توترات اسرائيل
تزداد حيث نقلت وكالة سانا عن
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن برفع
السرية عن معلومات استخباراتية
المقاتلين الذين قتلوا في مصنع
للصلب. يطلق كتابا جديدا لتوثيق
اوكرانيا. موسكو غاضبة من تدفق
الاسلحة الغربية لا سيما
المحتل مستهدفا بعض النقاط جنوب
مدينة دمشق مضيفة ان الدفاعات
بتوجيه قائد القوات البرية في
الجيش الايراني العميد حيدري
على خلفية عملية العسكرية
الروسية في اوكرانيا وهو ذات
ولتوانيا الى وجود عسكري اقوى
لحلف شمال الاطلسي لدول البلطيق
روسيا ستضعف الاقتصاد الروسي
وستلزم بوتين بوقف حربه على
الروسي سيرجي لافروف من ان روسيا
سترد على الامدادات الغربية من
الجوية السورية تصدت للصواريخ
واسقطت معظمها بحسب الوكالة
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي وذلك من
اجل توفير الارضية لاحتجاجات
تحذيرا الى اسرائيل مهددا بتسوية
تل ابيب وحيفاء بالارض في حال
الصواريخ الامريكية المتطورة الى
اوكرانيا واليوم تؤكد ان رد
شاملة هل تجرؤ اسرائيل على عملية
خطيرة كهذه? الرد الايراني جاء
المرة كان باعتراض طائراتكم. لكن
مرة اخرى سيكون الرد قاسيا. هكذا
الغزو بحسب وزارة الدفاع
البريطانية. وقال وزير الدفاع
اذرعته في المنطقة مؤكدا ان
ايران لن تكون في مأمن اذا تسببت
في ايذاء بلاده. ونقلت قناة
الحرس الثوري الايراني عن مصادر
تتصرف بقوة ضد رأس الاخطبوط
الايراني بشكل مباشر وليس فقط
اسرائيل تعيش التوترات. قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان اسرائيل
البريطاني بن والاس اذا حافظ
المجتمع الدولي على دعمه فان
وكورية جنوبية وحلقوا فوق البحر
الاصفر. وفي بيانهم اوضح الحلفاء
الصينية ان جيشها اتخذ اجراءات
معقولة للتعامل مع تصرفات كندا
بكين هذا? لندن في فوهة المدفع.
رغم تهديدات بوتين. قررت المملكة
قالها اصحاب العيون الضيقة
لاستراليا وكندا. فهل يكفي رد
استرالية وكندية كانت قد دخلت
المجال الجوي الصيني متجاهلة
السابعة التي يمكن ان تجرى في اي
وقت. هم يتوقعون تجربة سابعة لكن
وكندا من عواقب وخيمة لاي
استفزاز. وقالت بكين ان طائرات
التحذيرات المتكررة من الجانب
الصيني. بينما تقول الدفاع
واستراليا وقد احتجاجا رسميا عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسية. الرد هذه
والعالم اذا اجرت كوريا الشمالية
تجربة نووية. الامريكان لم
استفزاز من كوريا الشمالية لكن
ماذا عن المجنون? كيف سيكون رده
يكتفوا بتصريحات بل انهم ردوا
على تجربة اطلاق كيم جونغ ثمانية
يانج اكملت استعداداتها على ما
يبدو لما ستكون تجربتها النووية
انه سيكون هناك رد قوي وواضح من
الولايات المتحدة الجنوبية
صواريخ في بحر اليابان بمناورة
شكلتها عشرون مقاتلة امريكية
ابيب ودمشق? واشنطن تغازل الرياض
مرة اخرى فما هي غايتها? استفزاز
ستكون نهاية التوترات بينهما وسط
ارتفاع التوترات ايضا بين تل
غزت موسكو اوكرانيا? فهل يفيد
ذلك بشيء لايقاف الحرب? ما الذي
هل يمكن توقع التصرفات وردود
افعال المجنون? الرد دعت الصين
لندن على ذلك? الصين تطلق تحذيرا
شديد اللهجة لاستراليا وكندا.
دفع روسيا في جزيرة ثعبان. ايران
واسرائيل الى اين المصير? وكيف
استراليا الى وقف الاستفزازات
الخطيرة كما حذرت بكين استراليا
يا ترى? يرد الممثل الامريكي
الخاص لكوريا الشمالية بان بيونج
المجنون. اعلنت نائبة وزير
الخارجية الامريكي ويندي شيرمان
باسلحة قد تجعلهم في مواجهة
مباشرة امام روسيا. فهل تقوى
مجنون كوريا الشمالية. فهل يكون
رد كيم نويا هذه المرة? المانيا
كييف بعيدا عن حدودها. فهل يخفي
الروس الحرب ضد بريطانيا.
الاسلحة بعيدة المدى لاوكرانيا
من خلال تكثيف جهودها لدفع قوات
تتجاهل تحذيرات بوتين وتدعو
لزيادة القوة العسكرية للنايتو
الجنون نوع من انواع الضعف الا
لدى مجنون كوريا فهو عنوان
لقوته. الجنون هو ان يفعل
الانسان او يقول اشياء لا
انهم استعرضوا قدرتهم القوية
ورغبتهم في الرد سريعا وبدقة على
فهل يتوقفون عن تجاول تصريحات
بكين? ومايدن يكشف السرية عن كيف
في البطيخ. هل تدر برلين عواقب
ما يطلبون. الانجليز يمدون كييف
وروسيا توسع اهدافها. فهل تمتد
حربها الى اوروبا? دعونا بها.
يستوعبها. فهل يستوعب الامريكان
ما يفعلونه اليوم? واشنطن تستفز